mark Hawkinson asks can an antimatter
reaction cause a spaceship to have
negative mass and allow faster than
light travel no so it was intriguing
when any matter was hypothesized yeah
and discovered it was the natural
question to ask does antimatter have
anti mass yeah
and if it has anti mass does it have
anti-gravity mm-hmm all right so these
were intriguing you know what is the
negative sign go is what the question
turned out to be turned out antimatter
has opposite properties only in its
quantum state which is a shorthand for
saying particles have spin and there's a
measurements of particles that have that
that that exist in the quantum in the
quantum world and they're opposite for
antimatter and the existence of their
mass is not and it's just it's an
unfortunate fact otherwise we would be
so rocking the universe if we had anti
might like if we could even just shoot
us something the size of a dime oh yeah
antimatter anti mass we'd be all over it
we would love all up in it huh